Hi there, and welcome to the
third annual Google Security
Update, where I will attempt
to answer the question,
what has Google security
done for you lately?
So as you will have figured
out from the description,
I'm Stephan Somogyi, I work
on Google's security privacy
engineering team.
And I also have the
good fortune of working
with a bunch of startups at GV,
which is Alphabet's early stage
startup venture arm.
I also advise Google
Capital, which
works with later stage companies
on security privacy stuff.
But most importantly,
the charter
of Google's security and
privacy engineering team
is to protect our
users and their data.
Which is a really simple
statement to make,
but it hides a lot of
complexity underneath.
So if we do our job
right, this is what
happens-- absolutely nothing.
You get the blank slide.
If we do our job correctly,
the user doesn't notice.
And this is the ideal
that we strive for.
For those of you
who saw the keynote,
you will have seen that Dave
Burke mentioned security
as a top theme for Android N.
And further on in the keynote,
Erik Kay made a
point that security
is absolutely critical
to Allo and Duo, both,
even to the point of adding
some very specific security
features, including end-to-end
encryption, and other things
to incognito chats.
So security is very
pervasive throughout Google--
it's not simply and only
a function of the security
and privacy engineering team.
So the fact that
you're here indicates
that you also think security
and privacy are important.
But before I continue, I want
to clear up a few things.
I worked on some of
the projects that I'm
going to be talking about today,
but certainly not all of them.
There is only one of me.
And I'm also just
a representative
for my hundreds of teammates
all around the world, who work
on this stuff day in, day out.
And this is a couple
hundred of them.
So let's start by also
setting the stage.
Since I have a fairly
limited amount of time,
I'm only going to be providing
a highlights reel of stuff
that we've done over the
past approximately year.
If you want to check out
some of the previous videos,
they're up on YouTube from
previous annual security
updates.
With that, let's talk about TLS.
So protecting data in transit is
really crucial between endpoint
and back end.
You get integrity
guarantees for the data,
that it was protected
from all adulteration.
You get confidentiality,
because it's encrypted.
You also get a certain
amount of identity assurance,
because you know that you
are talking to the server
that you think you
are talking to.
One important meta-thing that
happened during the last year
is that we used to be
able to use SSL and TLS
interchangeably, but no more.
There is no such thing as a
secure version of SSL anymore.
So SSL bad, RLS good-- TLS 1.2
best, TLS 1.3 is happening,
but it's not there yet.
So in terms of current
best practices,
RLS 1.2 is the way to go.
So we've been busy
on the TLS front.
Last September, we announced
the beginnings of the blogger
transition to HTTPS.
We knew that we were a
little bit late with this,
but doing this right is
actually fairly complicated.
Blogger delivers a lot of
user-generated content, which
brings with it the risk of mixed
content warnings and browsers.
And so we wanted
to be careful, we
wanted to be very
deliberate with this.
So last September,
we added a checkbox
that anybody with
a blog on Blogger
could turn on the checkbox and
start debugging whether or not
they had any mixed
content issues.
Earlier this month,
first week of May,
we hit our next big milestone--
all Blogspot blogs now
have an HTTPS
version by default.
There's nothing that anybody
has to do about this.
And that's very much by design--
it's like the blank slide,
if we do our job
right, nobody has
to spend extra effort
and nobody notices.
We also added HTTPS
redirect, so that if people
come to your blog via
HTTP, we will automatically
redirect them to
the HTTPS version,
if that's what you want.
And since we know that mixed
content can still be a problem,
we've actually added some
helpful mixed content
warning tools, to help you debug
those within your own blog.
Now Chrome continues to be
at the center of a lot of TLS
and certificate-related work.
One of the things that
we're doing right now,
for example, is via opt-in
collecting invalid certificate
chains, because we're always
interested in figuring out
what it is out there in the wild
that triggers HTTPS warnings.
One thing that we discovered
during previous research
projects is that a very large
proportion of TLS warnings
are simply the result of
miss-set local clocks.
So dead motherboard
batteries, or other reasons
why the local clock
is not right--
if it's too far in
the past, or too far
in the future, that is
technically a problem.
It is technically an error.
But is it really
inhibiting, or otherwise
adversely affecting the user
security at that moment?
Not so much.
And we also know from our
user experience research
that users get security
warning fatigue.
So we think very carefully
about whether or not
we should be presenting a
warning, whether there really
is something for the user to do.
In this case, it's relatively
mundane-- set your clock,
and you'll be fine.
But in general,
we're always looking
for ways of minimizing
the warnings that we're
going to show.
Looking into the
near future, we're
going to be updating some of
Chrome's connection security
warnings in M52.
Right now it's still in dev,
but the code has landed,
so if you want to take a look
you can take a look in dev,
and it'll be in stable as
soon as M52 goes stable.
For those of you who
didn't have the opportunity
to see Emily Stark from
the Chrome security team
give her talk on
HTTPS myth-busting,
I definitely commend to you
checking out the YouTube video
which has already been posted.
She lays waste to
a lot of the myths
out there in the
world about HTTPS--
whether they're
performance related,
configuration related,
fundamentally the truth
will be out, and Emily
explains most, if not
all, of the things
that have really
been occupying a lot of the
people who we hear from,
and what prevents them
from switching to HTTPS.
So if you want to hear more
about HTTPS myth-busting,
check out Emily's video.
Another thing that we're
very happy to talk about
is that our ads delivery
is now effectively 100%.
A year ago, here at I/O, we were
aiming for 50% by last June.
We got there, but
more importantly,
as of today, with the exception
of some parts of the world
that block or otherwise
degrade HTTPS traffic,
we are delivering 100%
of our ads via HTTPS.
And this is a really
big deal for publishers.
This is a one and a
half year project that
came to its final culmination.
And what made it hard is
because mixed content manifests
in a lot of different ways.
With ad options,
we may very well
wind up displaying ads from
any of a number of different ad
companies.
And so we needed
to ramp up the fact
that we wanted to
pull ads via HTTPS.
And this is why this took
us over a year and a half.
The ramp-up now has
gone to 100%-- again,
except for users that are
somehow environments that block
or degrade HTTPS-- but
this is also a really,
really good time to give
a shout-out to Wired
and to Buzzfeed, both of which
have started writing about
their transition to HTTPS.
So if you are a
publisher, and you
are struggling with what
the transition means
and what the mechanics
are of this transition,
go check out those articles.
They're very edifying.
We also have a long
history of shining light
on how we do stuff.
And this past year
was no different.
In mid-March, we launched our
latest transparency report,
the HTTSP Report.
We first looked closely at
ourselves and our own services,
because we wanted to find
areas that we could actually
optimize, and things where
we could do better on HTTPS.
And then we cast our automated
gaze out into the world
to look at sites, to see
how they were doing HTTPS,
if they were doing HTTPS,
and whether or not the server
configurations were as
modern as they could be.
There's a lot of
additional detail
in this transparency report.
If this is of interest to
you, you should definitely
go and check it out.
In late March, Gmail enabled the
display of a very small number
of red pixels.
You see there, that small
open red lock indicates
whether Gmail received an e-mail
message from the outside world
in unencrypted form--
i.e, not over TLS.
If we do receive
the message via TLS,
we display nothing,
because we believe
that is what it should be.
Again, the blank slide.
What's really amazing
about this indicator
is the effect that it
actually had out email,
on the internet at large.
About two years ago, when
we released the Safer Email
Transparency Report,
that was in June of 2014,
it took about a year to increase
the outbound email-- the email
that we send-- by about 10%.
Now remember, both sides
need to participate in this.
This isn't something that
we can do unilaterally.
In fact, Gmail has been
able to send email over TLS
since its introduction in 2004.
So 10%, over the
course of a year,
we were pretty happy with that,
until this lock came along.
So before we introduced
the lock-- and this is
a screenshot straight from
the Safer Email Transparency
Report, so this is public
data-- we were at about 58%
of the inbound traffic.
And within 45 days,
we had jumped by 20%.
So this is the power
of transparency.
It is really also
worth mentioning
that the Gmail team is
hard at work within the ITF
to define SMTP strict transport
security, which is the mail
equivalent of HSTS, which
is the web version that then
demonstrates and defines a
mechanism for requiring HTTPS,
or in this case,
just TLS for SMTP.
Also was shouting out to
the Android security team,
those of you who were in
Adrian Ludwig's talk yesterday
already know this,
but another form
of transparency
that we believe in
is things like the
annual year in review--
there have now
been two of those,
the most recent one was
published last April.
And it talks about the
security-related changes
within the Android ecosystem.
Again, I encourage
you to have a look
if this stuff interests you.
Auto updates today
are best practice.
Chrome has been
doing it since it was
introduced as a beta in 2008.
And here we are,
eight years later,
and broad swaths of the
industry have followed suit.
This shows the last year's
worth of Chrome updates.
And you will see very rapid,
very sharp transitions
between the major versions.
We update about 80% of the user
base within the first week.
We trend to about 90%
in the second week,
and that's when the long
tail really kicks in.
And there's an important lesson
here for all developers-- which
is that solid engineering
practices, and quality
assurance, really matter,
because users never
would have accepted auto
updates if we pushed out
crashy updates.
But stable means stable, and
the Chrome Stable channel
is very much
intended and designed
to be that stable release for
the vast majority of our users.
And as a result, users
have accepted auto update.
The other importance, of course,
is the security benefits.
The reason auto updates
matter for security
is because this is how we get
risk mitigation, bug fixes,
and security updates onto
users' devices really quickly,
and ideally without the user
having to worry about it.
The quicker that we can get
security updates running
on these devices, the quicker
we can get them protected.
This has been the case
for Chrome all along,
this has been the case
for Chrome OS all along.
And over the past year, Android
has been making big steps
forward with their
monthly security updates--
there have been 10 so
far, and we look forward
to continuing this process.
Dave Burke even explicitly
mentioned during his keynote
that we're working hard to
make updates even more seamless
in Android N. So
this is very much
a multi-platform
concerted effort.
Now, a more recent
product of ours,
that also embraces auto updates
for user security, is OnHub.
We launched our first OnHub
router late last October,
and so far it's been
doing very, very well.
Users really like the fact
that it's as plug-and-play
as you can make a home router.
What we haven't talked
about, until today,
is that it was architected
and designed and developed
with strong security in mind
from the very beginning.
So much like Chrome OS devices,
OnHub auto updates-- users
don't have to worry
about a thing.
And just like it's
a good security
feature for Chrome
and Chrome OS,
It's a great security
feature for OnHub.
Those of you who try
to vulnerabilities
will have heard of the
great glibc vulnerability
earlier this year, it
made the headlines.
It allowed remote
attackers to cause anything
from a denial of service
due to a crash, to arbitrary
code execution.
It was not a fun type of vuln.
The entire OnHub fleet
that had been out there,
since late October,
was patched three days
after public availability
of that vuln,
and public disclosure.
So this is the power
of auto updates.
Not one user had to worry
about it-- not one user
had to download anything.
It just happened automatically.
Now OnHub also believes
in defense in depth,
so it has verified boot.
Each OnHub device actually
contains a trusted platform
module, a security
processor, that
allows us to apply assurance
to a variety of systems,
and approaches, to
what we do with OnHub.
For Android users, that also
allows the OnHub mobile app
to verify that it's talking
to an actual OnHub router,
that the right software
is at the other end.
There's a lot of verification
validation in both directions.
The OnHub security team
also tracks the provenance
of third party
hardware, software,
and firmware very carefully.
So if a vulnerability is
found anywhere in that stack,
we know who to talk to, we can
get the response and mitigation
underway quickly, and we now
know-- because we proved it
with the glibc vuln-- we
can actually get fixes
out very, very quickly.
So it may seem
counter-intuitive,
but cloud management
of the OnHub device
is also a feature, because your
Google account protects access
to your OnHub, as well.
So all the protections that
we create for your Google
accounts, apply here.
Anything that we
do in the future
to further protect
your Google account,
will also benefit you here.
Most other routers
require that you
log in to a local web
server on the device--
these do not have the
greatest history of security,
especially if the updates
don't happen very frequently.
And they have been a
common vector of attack
from bad actors.
So the cloud-based
nature of managing OnHub
actually gives us a bunch
of security benefits
that are not
necessarily intuitive,
but the more we
thought about it,
the more we realized
that this actually is
a significant security benefit.
And we believe so
strongly, and we
are so confident in
the security of OnHub,
that we're adding it to
our vulnerability rewards
program effective immediately.
So last year, we gave
out a lot of money
to a lot of people
for a lot of bugs.
We are already on
track this year
for it to be at least as
rewarding as 2015 was.
So last June, we added
Android to the VRP,
and we just added OnHub.
In March, we actually kicked
things up a notch on the Chrome
front, on two specific aspects.
For Chrome OS, we have
increased the top reward
from $50,000 US to $100,000,
for a persistent compromise
of a Chrome book in guest mode.
With great research,
comes great reward.
We're also extending
the reward program scope
to include rewards for bypasses
of Chrome Safe Browsing
download protection features.
So if you find a way to get
around the download protection,
there's definitely a
vulnerability reward
in your future.
There's a lot more detail that
you can find on the VRP page.
I'll be posting a lot of these
links to the Spaces space
for this session
after this talk,
so you don't have to
furiously write down any URLs.
I'll post them all there.
Another aspect of the
vulnerability rewards program
that may not be as clear
and as obvious to others,
but is very important to us,
is our patch rewards program.
We actually reward
security patches
to key open source
projects, even
if they have no association
to Google whatsoever.
Because we think that's
the right thing to do.
We believe your Google
account is your most valuable
Google asset, since
that's what gates access
to all of your data, and all
of your services across Google.
And our research shows that
Google accounts are considered
most valuable amongst accounts
from various service providers
out there on the black
market, which is a detail that
pleases us greatly.
Now Adrian said yesterday
that with the introduction
of fingerprint unlock, the use
of the lock screen on Nexus
devices went from 50% to 90%.
So only half the people
who had Nexus devices
had any kind of lock screen--
and with the introduction
of fingerprint, and its ease
of use, that one up to 90%.
So usability really,
really matters.
So this is why we started
work, five or so years ago,
on the technology
behind security key.
We worked together with our
fellow members of the FIDO
alliance-- which is an
industry consortium dedicated
to open standards for
strong authentication.
Now the core technology within
a security key like this
is called U2F-- it's short
for universal second factor.
And it's this really great
combination of more security,
with more usability.
That circle in the middle
there, that's a touch sensor.
It's not biometric--
as long as you
are as conductive as a
typical live human being,
you can trigger it.
And what it does is gate the
actual authentication process.
The reductionist view
of a successful phish,
or a successful account
credential compromise,
is that the attacker can
reuse the credentials
at a time of their choosing.
By requiring the
proof of presence,
by requiring that touch,
we break phishing.
And effectively, you
become largely unphishable,
with a device like this
protecting your account.
Now since we introduced
security key for Google accounts
in October of 2014, this
has been the trend line.
So it's definitely going
in the right direction.
At this point, we've enabled it
both for our consumer accounts,
as well as for our
Google for Work accounts.
And other companies have
started adopting it, as well--
including Dropbox,
including GitHub.
Now the security
team works closely
with Google's trust and safety
team on a variety of projects,
as well.
Trust and safety's charter
is, among other things,
to protect our users by
creating and enforcing policies
around spam, fraud, abuse,
and inappropriate content.
Which means that they're usually
the ones on the front lines
when dealing with
fraud-related issues.
Now if you're an
AdWords customer,
it can be both very
expensive and very stressful
if you lose control
over the account that
controls your AdWords.
And this, unfortunately, happens
a bit more often than any of us
would prefer.
So
The trust and
safety team has been
working with a cross-section
of AdWords customers
in North and South America,
and in Europe on an experiment.
We gave some of these
customers very small numbers
of security keys to
see whether or not
we could move the needle on
account compromise for AdWords,
specifically.
We haven't actually been
running this experiment
for very long yet,
but so far, the data
has been quite compelling.
It does indeed lead to
a noticeable decrease
in customers losing control
over their accounts,
and thus it leads to
a very real fraud loss
reduction for everybody.
Now, even though the
experiment isn't over,
it has been so fruitful
that we are actually
going to be expanding
this to Asia, as well,
to see if by taking an
increasingly global approach,
we can learn even more
stuff than we have so far.
Which brings us to our cloud.
Another important
thing that we've
done over the course
of the last year
is launch our cloud identity
and access management
for all Google Cloud
platform customers.
So first of all, terminology
check-- authentication
is what we've been talking about
in the context of security key,
proving that you are the
legitimate user of a given
account.
Authorization is that, based on
the authenticated account, gate
access to resources
as appropriate.
And together these are referred
to as IM-- identity and access
management.
So we heard loud and clear
from our cloud customers
that what they needed was a
very thoughtfully designed
and implemented access control
to their cloud resources.
And as of today, there
are 20 predefined roles
that meet the vast majority
of the needs of our cloud
customers.
And though we've heard some
feedback about the desire
to self-define roles,
we're not quite there yet.
But if you're a customer and
you want self-defined roles,
look for those coming
within the next year.
So a lot of additional
information,
including some videos from
our GCP Next conference,
which happened two months ago
in San Francisco, up on YouTube.
So if you're interested in
this, in IM on our cloud,
go check those out.
So one security system
here at Google, that's
been around for
almost a decade now,
and it reaches far
and wide is called
Safe Browsing, where we protect
users and their devices.
We do this across
many platforms,
across Windows, across
Mac OSX, across Linux.
And we protect users
from an assortment
of badness-- whether
it's malware or phishing,
or other kinds of
social engineering.
And if you ever see one
of these red screens,
please consider enabling
this little check box,
because it gives us a bunch
of additional information
about how you got
there, and what
was the trail that led you to
this particular potentially
compromised site, but certainly
a site that we know is bad.
That telemetry
that we get, we can
use to help everybody who
consumes Safe Browsing's
data, which is a
variety of platforms,
and a variety of browsers
on those platforms.
Now, a relatively
new kind of badness
that you may not have heard
of, is unwanted software--
which we abbreviate like this.
And we've taken to calling,
"ooze," because saying UwS lot
is very, very cumbersome.
We've been working against
ooze for well over a year.
We're far from
done yet, but we've
made some really
significant steps forward.
And if you check out
on our security blog,
we have a fairly comprehensive
post from last December,
detailing some of
things that we've
done, some of things
that we're still planning
on doing in the future.
So if you want details about
that, the blog's the way to go.
Another facet of social
engineering-related protection
and safe browsing,
is our enforcement
against deceptive
download buttons.
They've been against our
policy from the get-go.
But starting in
February, we announced
increased enforcement.
And this was a very popular
choice, judging by the response
that we got on
Twitter and elsewhere,
because these deceptive
downloads lead users to ooze,
and they lead users to
other forms of badness.
So this is one way that we can
help protect a lot of users
on the internet at scale.
One of the most
protective things
that we did over this past year,
is extend more Safe Browsing
protection down to
the mobile device.
So all the existing
protections that you
have already on the platform--
Safety Net, verify apps--
are absolutely crucial to
protecting Android, itself.
What we've done now is
add, on top of that,
and provide more protection
against social engineering,
and malware, within
Chrome on Android.
And since we're prone to
measuring things, and counting
stuff, we recently sat
down and figured out
that Safe Browsing,
in total, across all
of its supported
platforms today,
protects well over
2 billion devices.
Which means that,
odds are today,
even if you don't know it,
there's a high likelihood
that Safe Browsing made
your internet experience
that much safer,
because of how pervasive
we have managed to make it be.
Now, while we were developing
Safe Browsing for mobile,
we realized very early on
that for the vast majority
of the world, cellular
data costs money.
So pushing protective data
updates down to a mobile device
is something that is potentially
very costly to the user,
and we needed to be extremely
respectful of our user's data
usage.
And so we developed the
guiding principle, which
is maximum protection per bit.
Every single bit that
Safe Browsing sends down
to the local device
needs to matter.
So since this is a
developers' conference,
we want to give you an idea of
how we approached this problem,
and what we did to
actually hit this.
So first off, I'll
give away a punchline.
We do know at this point
that what we did works,
even though it's only been
live for about half a year,
it is very clear to us, based
on the number of warning
interstitials that
we display to users,
that this protection has been
highly, highly effective.
At times, we have shown
five times the warnings
for social engineering on
mobile devices per million pages
than we do on desktop.
At times, we've shown over
2x the malware warnings.
This is not an indicator
of a lack of security
on the mobile
platform, what this
is, is an indicator
of the interest
that the bad guys
have in getting people
on the mobile platform.
And the fact that we're
showing these warnings,
means that we already
know about the badness,
and we can help protect
users even better.
So how do we do this?
How did we pursue maximum
protection per bit?
So on the server
side, we focused
on minimizing the
amount of data.
And we did this by reorganizing
how we handled these bad links.
We know, for example, that
certain campaigns of badness
out there in the world are
geo-specific-- they're only
relevant to certain
parts of the world.
So there's no point in showing
a mobile device user, halfway
around the world,
any information
and pushing any of that
information down to the device
if they're never going
to see the campaign.
We also have information
about the platform
relevance of a given
link, and its badness.
And we also rank the
protectiveness, or the badness,
of a given link, so that we
know if a particular link is
actually followed
more frequently,
people are more likely
to be attacked that way.
And so we can
stack-rack that up.
So we have lots of ways of
filtering the optimal dataset
for any given device,
based on what device it is,
which country it's
in, and what's
going on in the
world at the time.
Now the client has a very
good idea of its bandwidth.
So it can effectively
communicate to us
and tell us that it can
only handle so many updates,
and get so much information,
based on its current network
conditions.
So this is where the
stack ranking comes in.
If that device can only
accept, say, 10 bad links,
let's give that device the
10 most protective bits
of information that we can
give it at that very moment.
Now, what we did is we
reorganized some of the data
structures for the wire protocol
that we actually send through.
And then we sat down with
Google's compression team,
and worked out whether
or not there was a way
to further reorganize the
data structures to make them
that much more compressible.
And as a result of all the
data minimization on the server
side, and the increased
compressibility
of the data, that ultimately
improves and then gets
decompressed on
the client side--
we really think
that we got as close
as we can to truly delivering
maximal protection per bit.
So how do you, as developers,
take advantage of this?
All this technology is part
of the latest Safe Browsing
protocol, version 4, which we're
launching right here, right
now at I/O. You can find
out a bunch more information
on the blog post,
which went live
a couple minutes ago,
probably right around the time
that this talk began.
The most important parts
of developer documentation,
that are here at this URL,
which I'll post to Spaces later,
all these details are available.
But even better for you, is
we have a reference client
implementation,
which he wrote in Go,
and we put it up at this link.
We'd like to highlight two very
specific things about protocol
version 4, since we're
introducing it now,
and this is going to
be new to all of you.
First of all, if you do
have a version 3 client
implementation, please
start transitioning now.
We are beginning the
deprecation process,
and there is no reason
to stick with version 3.
Version 4 is better
in any possible metric
that we can think of.
So please start that process.
But if you are on
Android, odds are
you're not going to have to do
any work at all, because we've
done all the work for you.
We didn't get it quite
done in time for I/O,
but we're working to deliver
a really simple Android
API that you can call to verify
goodness or badness of a URL.
You will not have to implement
a full version for a client,
and its aware
protocol yourselves.
It's really important for
a user's battery life,
for a user's cellular phone
bills, for all of these details
to only have a single up-to-date
copy of the Safe Browsing data,
locally on a device.
And we're going to
do that for you,
and provide this as
a system service.
Once the API is ready to
use, we'll put up a blog post
and we'll let you know
exactly how to use it.
So one thing we've gotten
feedback on in previous I/Os
is that you're interested
in best practices for how
to protect yourselves.
First off, please stop reusing
passwords across services.
This is the number
one most helpful thing
that you can do
for your attackers.
Knock it off, please.
It's not helpful.
Second of all, please look
to secure your accounts
as much as possible.
Now, there are a variety
of different devices
that support the
U2F-- these come
in a variety of different
colors right now,
this one is actually one of
mine, you can see it's scuffed.
It's fairly well used.
This one, for example, is
not quite available yet,
but it supports U2F over
three different connectivity
mechanisms.
There's a USB port,
it supports NFC,
and it also supports
Bluetooth Low Energy.
There are devices out there
where we can't get access
to the NFC interface.
There are mobile
devices where it's not
easy to use USB-- so we
need to be able to run U2F
over any of these protocols.
And there's a
variety of solutions
from a variety of
different vendors
out there available
in the world today.
Back to my slides, please.
Thank you.
The next thing we'd like
to encourage you to do
is to use RLS wherever possible.
This also includes
software updates.
There have been a number of
TLS-related vulnerabilities
out in the world.
And I was personally quite
dismayed to see some developers
check for the availability
of updates via HTTP-- often
they'll get the link to the
updated binary via HTTP,
and then they'll
download it over HTTP.
And then we will have heard,
oh, but the binary is signed,
everything will be fine.
Except the problem is,
if you send the link down
to the device over
HTTP, and you actually
do have a man in the
middle attacker there,
they're going to change
that link to something
that they control.
So the user, your
user, might never
actually get the binary
you intended for them.
So just do the simple and
straightforward thing-- put
HTTPS everywhere.
It's a lot better for you, it's
a lot better for your users,
and it's a lot better for your
reputation as a developer.
Now, a lot of what
we've talked about
is protection scale--
billions of devices.
But since 2012, we've also
been showing very, very focused
warnings to a very, very small
percentage of our user base.
And if you should ever
see a warning like this,
please take heed.
We'll give you a bunch of
advice on that Learn More link.
Please don't ignore it.
None of the advice
is rocket science,
it's not super secret
stuff, it's basically
turn on two-factor
authentication,
be reasonable with your
security precautions.
And we are astonished at
how few people actually
follow this advice, even when
we warn them very, very clearly.
If you get this warning,
please don't ignore it.
And if you ever
get this warning,
your security posture really
should become a priority
over your convenience.
Now, one of the
things that I haven't
had nearly as much time
as I wanted to talk about
is all the research that we do.
But one item of research from
last July, in particular,
is worthwhile in this context,
where we asked both experts
and non-experts alike about what
the most protective thing is
that they could think of.
And this is how it worked out.
This graphic is actually
in the blog post,
so you don't-- you're
all taking pictures.
You don't have to
take a picture.
There's an actual image online.
I will send you
the URL in Spaces.
Really, it's OK.
But one of the most
interesting things to me
is that the expert advice,
number one thing to do,
is install software updates.
Which brings us all the way back
to all the auto update stuff.
It actually works.
And there is great consensus
across the industry,
across platforms,
across companies,
that this is the most
user beneficial security
thing that you can do.
And that's why, also, safe and
secure and verified software
updates are super important.
So this is where our
security blog is.
We've actually done 41 blog
posts since last year's I/O,
with a whole variety
of additional content.
I haven't had the time to
talk about a lot of stuff--
I could have gone on for
another couple of hours, easily.
Among the things that I didn't
have time to go into in-depth
were ephemeral IDs for Eddystone
BLE beacon implementation.
So if you're interested
in privacy preserving
technologies, particularly
in the context of BLE,
check out ephemeral IDs.
It's very clever technology, and
it's there exclusively and very
focusedly to protect
individual users' privacy.
I didn't get a chance to talk
about certificate transparency,
which is a core technology
for trust out there,
and is growing in
importance with every day.
I definitely didn't
talk enough about all
of our research, all the
research that we do out there.
I didn't talk enough
about the things
that we deprecated
over this last year.
So SSL v3 we got rid of, RC4
and SHA-1 also deprecated.
I didn't get a chance
to talk about using
Google Brain for
anti-spam and Gmail,
which turned out
to be a very, very
effective tool in combating
that sort of thing.
And we also didn't have
a chance to dig deep
into the importance
of notifications.
Because one thing
that we've found
is if we discover a website
that has been compromised,
and that has become
bad for its users,
we have determined
that the quicker we
can get a notification
to the site operator,
the quicker they can
remediate, and the quicker
they can actually protect
all of their visitors.
And we did a bunch of
research last summer,
and recently published a
paper, based on this research.
So notifications
about security really
do matter, and
really do help users.
There's a huge spectrum
of security stuff,
particularly in the
realm of human factors
and in communication,
that make a material
difference to the security
of all of our users.
It's not just about the crypto,
it's not just about the auth,
it's not just about
the technology.
So as I said, I'll put
a whole bunch of links
to videos, and to blogs, and to
websites up on Spaces shortly
after this talk.
I just ran out of time.
Thanks very much.
I'll be around for a little
while, but thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]